exploding moons exorcist moms and
bowling this show has it all and as the
handler says do you think an explanation
of sorts is owing you got that damn
right so in this video we're gonna take
a look at Netflix's the Umbrella Academy
starting with a deep dive into the
ending and finishing up with some other
cool details you may have missed now if
you want to skip ahead and take a look
at what I'll be covering I've left time
links in the description just don't jump
too far in time or you could end up like
this
the final episode begins with a
flashback that simply says long ago yet
the spaceships and futuristic atmosphere
suggest it's in the future that is
unless this is an earth according to the
graphic novels of which this show is
based off
Reginald Hargreaves is actually an
extraterrestrial steve blackman the
showrunner said we'll learn more about
harus past next season so for now we can
only speculate he says goodbye to his
love whose death may somehow be involved
with why everyone on this planet is
leaving it's likely this planet is dying
or facing its own apocalypse she gives
him her violin which is later given to
Vanya
which in turn becomes the white phial in
in the comics Vanya is villain code name
is the white violin and it also happens
to be the title of the final episode
will Vanya still be a villain and why
did they take her with them as number 5
explains the apocalypse will always
happen and Vanya will always be the
cause unless they take her with her and
fix her so it looks like next season
will focus on helping Vanya harness her
power fixing her with the hopes of
preventing the apocalypse once and for
all
back to Reginald we see him collect a
mysterious jar of floating dust now you
may have missed it but there's a cut
here which suggests a bit of time has
passed after he says his goodbyes and
that she is likely dead here the
showrunner hasn't disclosed what this is
but to me it seems symbolic of letting
one's ashes go perhaps it is her spirit
being said unto the universe and how
cool would it be if there were 43 of
those floating sprites in there the same
amount of children who miraculously were
born that fateful day in October of 1989
Reginald is suddenly in 1928 earth with
no money to his name you can see he's
taking a ship on third
mr. Dawson is joining us from the third
class if he is indeed from another
planet with more advanced technology he
likely used this to his advantage on
earth to become the billionaire that he
is creating breakthroughs in biology
like Pogo or technology like robot mom
it's when he arrives in the new city
that he buys an umbrella shop which will
later become the Umbrella Academy and
there's great juxtaposition with the
founding of the academy followed by
Vanya completely destroying it Vanya was
locked in what's known as an anechoic
chamber a chamber devoid of any sound
since her power relies on harnessing
sound and converting it into energy this
is the perfect cell for her but what
Reginald and the others didn't take into
account was that the anechoic chambers
are said to be so quiet that you can
hear your own heartbeat Vanya then uses
the sound of her heart to completely
destroy the iron door that previously
held her inside she has been taken over
by the trauma of her past we get a brief
glimpse of her alongside two younger
versions of herself both of whom Harbor
extreme resentment for their father and
siblings funny then experiences
flashbacks of how badly her siblings
treated her treating her as an outsider
because she wasn't special like them to
go on mission by you you have to help
her it's this resentment that causes her
to completely destroy the Academy Pogo
her mother and the world along with her
it's here we also get a glimpse of how
much further Klaus is powers can go for
most of the season closest powers have
been suppressed because he can't fully
harness them will under the influence of
drugs and narcotics now that he's
sobered up he can harness the power of
his dead brother Ben who saves Diego
from a falling piece of debris now Ben
is interesting because we never really
see how he died we do know that it was
when he was younger because of the
statue in the gardens which means that
when number 5 teleports the family and
we see them as their younger selves it's
entirely possible that Ben will be alive
and well in the upcoming season even
cooler is that Klaus can allow Ben to
manifest himself in reality using his
tentacle powers to make quick work of
the Commission's henchmen now we can
guess these goons are from the
Commission because of the gas mass which
we get a brief glimpse of in episode 6
now with Vanya on the loose the gang
decides to hit the lanes where they find
out Vania is scheduled to play her final
perform
that will unleash the apocalypse at the
icarus theater Icarus being a fitting
name a reference to the Greek myth of
Icarus overestimating the extent of his
powers flying too close to the Sun and
dying in the process much like how then
his powers will lead to her own
destruction
you'll also notice the name of the
Chamber Orchestra st. pluvial blue VM
Latin for rainy the only thing to stop
it an umbrella of course also these
dudes were totally here for a Kenny's
birthday a nice little detail that I
totally loved is that the Umbrella
Academy are still wearing their bowling
shoes in the final scene we also have
the matter of cha-cha and hazel hazel
decides to kill cha-cha on a freak car
crash so he can be with his love donut
Lady Agnes but cha-cha doesn't die
instead going on to continue her mission
of protecting Vanya because if she can
protect Vanya she'll make sure the
apocalypse is successful and get her
retirement now it's also important to
know why this apocalypse is happening in
the first place the Commission whose
purpose is to make sure the timeline is
kept intact has deemed that this is
necessary but why doesn't this mean the
end of everything but as the handler
says not everything just the end of
something so we never really get a solid
answer on that
hazel rushes back to Agnes and
immediately kills the handler without
any words not like the handler would
care anyway since back in episode 5 when
number 5 has a gun pointed at her she
says she'll just be replaced by another
so next season we can probably expect a
new foe from the Commission but hazel
isn't going in without a back-up plan he
has a briefcase hidden in the air duct
just like he did in episode 2 this
briefcase will allow him an egg miss to
warp just moments before the apocalypse
whether or not they've gone to live
happily ever after or will appear next
season is still unknown chacha on the
other hand has a final battle with diego
and it's fitting it's with him because
diego learned chacha was the one who
pulled the trigger on his love detective
eudora patch but with ChaCha's life in
his hands he decides to spare her
thinking of Eudora who he loved because
she always saw the good in people that
people can change but it's kind of all
for naught since she just dies a minute
later anyway you can also see here
likely attempting to call the commission
who is an answering
I'm sorry Michaels not hearing and
finally we have the climactic battle
between Vanya and the other members of
the Umbrella Academy they decide to all
attack her at the same time in the hopes
of knocking her out of her trance
allison is the only one who's successful
and aims the gun at her head but instead
of shooting her she aims off to the side
because Vanya spars are reliant on sound
the gun blast causes her to release all
our energy upward to the moon which
consequently crumbles and rains
apocalyptic rock on earth and with
nowhere to go number five suggests he
transport them all through time which
actually works we see them transform
back to children suggesting they may go
back to a time where their father is
still alive and finally get some answers
from him but since we now know number
five has this power it leaves endless
possibilities for where next season
could take us and it looks like ChaCha
detective Beeman and Sergeant cheddar
didn't make it out alive but notice how
cheddar here is reading the same
magazine Allison picked up about her
family earlier on in the season and with
the timeline potentially being reset who
knows who what or where next season will
take us now we're gonna jump into some
small details and questions you may have
missed
the Umbrella Academy logo contains the
words ooh Malibu via which roughly
translates from Latin to when evil
reigns you'll see the umbrella in the
top left which protects from the rain on
the right symbolized by the Lightning
the bottom right is the mask
representing the Umbrella Academy which
protects from evil on the Left of the
skull little is known about pogos
backstory other than he was created by
Reginald Hargreaves in Episode one Pogo
tells the family that Reginald made him
who he was today and he would forever be
in his debt my guess is that there's a
link between Pogo and the serum which
Hargreaves used to save Luther after the
biological attack after all when Luther
offers to give his blood to Alyson Pogo
says Luther can't because he has more in
common with his blood than with humans
number five stories one of the more
interesting in defiance of his father he
travelled through time and accidentally
stumbled on the apocalypse and couldn't
get back there he toiled for years until
saved by the handler who allowed him to
travel via the briefcases in exchange
for completing hits this allowed him
time to work on his calculations until
he was ready to travel back
but his calculations were wrong and he
came back as a kid but with the
knowledge of the decades he spent in
solitude one of the more interesting
aspects of number 5 was when he was
tasked to kill President John F Kennedy
in fact that's exactly what he was
tasked to do right before he conjured
the temporal portal which brought him
back in episode 1 but did he go through
with it if you play back the scene
you'll notice the gunshot sound occurs
after he's made his way through the
portal so know in this timeline he did
not Luthor lives on the moon because his
father told him to Luthor would do
anything for his dad since he was
fiercely loyal he was the last one to
leave the Umbrella Academy his loyalty
got him into the condition he's in today
and he later finds out that his father
never even read the reports he was
assigned to deliver for Reginald sending
Luthor to the moon was the only way to
give Luthor purpose after his horrific
accident and yes that's very messed up
close has a really weird scene in which
he supposedly talks to God in the form
of a young girl this actually happens in
the comics but God is depicted as a
grizzled cowboy riding a horse
showrunner Steve Blackman stated that
even the writers can decide whether or
not that's actually God so we're [ __ ]
out of luck getting an answer for that
last but not least how on earth did 43
women magically give birth in a day well
this is never explained in the show but
the comics hint that the 43 collectively
are the modern-day reincarnation of the
Messiah whether or not the show will
delve further into this is unknown but
with 43 born in the show only focusing
on 7 I wouldn't be surprised if more of
these children show up in season 2 I
hope you enjoyed this video make sure to
Luther smash that like button and I
heard a rumor that if you subscribe with
the Bell on you'll get more great videos
I also have a Twitter where you can get
in touch with me and get the latest on
what I'm working on until next time
remember daddy loves you very much